you do not introduce potato chips on a
sandwich hey I think it's a thing
everybody does instinctually like
sucking your thumb
well suck finding the nipple is the
thing that babies instinctually haha so
we just flew from LA to New York City to
try $1,000 ice cream two thousand dollar
pizza now back to dessert
here we go overhead cheesecake oh yeah
hey I'm not surprised by anything with
you that's right I'm a wild card throw
me out in the ocean never know is gonna
happen next
a wild card or wild carp both so today
we're going to eat three different
cheese cakes at three drastically
different price points to find out which
one is the most worth it at its price
first place we're going to
rhymes with buy green and no it's not
Irene it's Eileen why didn't you say it
rhymes with Irene they got lots and lots
of flavors and special treat we're
meeting Eileen I'm also kind of
awkwardly placed my head is like hugging
this chair
hi Adam you're weirdly placed on
[Music]
my name is Eileen Hassan oh you are at
Eileen special cheesecake today you guys
are going to be trying our classic New
York cheesecake the most asked question
is what's so special about cake the
special is for my mom
this was something that she made for
special occasions only because she said
it was too much work my full inheritance
was her recipe box I also have a mother
who's always made cheesecake my whole
life when the cheesecake was being made
everyone had to be quiet I totally
relate to that because I love to
tap-dance yeah I was never allowed
because the cake might fall okay your
cream cheese is going to go first and
then your sour cream you can put your
sugar your lemon and your vanilla add
your egg yolk slowly and then whip your
egg whites until they come to a peak the
last thing that you're going to do is
add your egg whites to the entire batter
and you kind of fold it in slowly we use
a honey Graham crust
we melt a little bit of butter with it
put it in a lined pan and we form the
crust which comes up around the edges
that's traditional New York cheesecake
people walking by the one a gourmet
dessert
they don't have to break the bank to be
able to enjoy it I want to note that
wariness of a play that has hearts or in
the perimeter it's so light on the
inside look at that most satisfying
thing is carving the tip off with the
fork rule
it's amazingly fluffy and rich how's
that possible
well it's cake this is so fluffy it's
honestly like approaching the texture of
the curds and cottage cheese that
doesn't sound as appealing as I wanted
anything about this crust it climbs the
edges of the cheesecake the crust is as
creamy as the rest of the cheesecake
it's just got that light Bunji delicate
don't even need to chew kind of texture
[Music]
that won't happen to you if you come
here and swear so what do you think of
Eileen's Wow
I think I'm a sucker for love if love
was a taste that's what about face like
she's a real mom making real dessert you
know what I'm ready for
one dude cheesecake facts the record for
the world's only god I haven't done any
puns this whole trip good the world's
largest cheesecake was made in 2013 at
the annual cheesecake something all
right
they had that every year guess how much
of weighed 10 tons ten tons look the
other day he told me there was a 5,000
foot piece of cheesecake was six
thousand ninety three pounds so three
tons I was off and now we're going to a
steak house
well you don't rent a steak cheesecake
you can just say cake
I'm slate Cheever resident party maker
and director of operations at SDK
I'm Harry uses I'm the executive
sous-chef SDK downtown today we'll be
making an orange dream cheesecake with a
bourbon sauce underneath pear but not
your daddy's Manhattan and twist on a
classic we start with a graham cracker
crust underneath with melted butter and
a little bit of confectionery sugar
press that down and then we add cream
cheese eggs vanilla extract and orange
zest underneath is a nice boozy sauce so
it really takes up that next level like
boo than anything we possibly can it's
true we dress the base of the plate with
our rum reduction cheesecake on top
orange segments on around the edges and
on top of the plate a little bit of
sugar and then we brulee it with a
blowtorch and this sauce and it kind of
grounds it it's a little heavier very
boozy really fun makes you feel thin and
that you really got your money's worth
nearly had a good time here the Bourbon
goes really well with the toasted brulee
across the top one invites the other you
want to take a sip and then a bite and
then a sip they're really well balanced
it's heaven on a plate for $12 heaven on
a plate
Steven it's 1204 so cocktail hour : 4
p.m.
hmm I'll go I'll hit you harder
at 12:04 p.m. the orange dream
cheesecake I love that it's brew late on
top cheesecake I think is a little bit
of a misnomer it's like closer to a
quiche than a cake yeah it's really like
a dissertation I'm gonna dig in whoa
notice a theme across pretty much every
food whatever you're gonna say can't be
as good as that lead up but go for it
it's always satisfying to put a fork in
yeah you know you know I mean just get
that nice like mmm Wow I really love the
hint of orange yeah it's like a
creamsicle and I like that it's not
taken over the top it's just the right
balance of flavor well it is the classic
pairing like you and me if we're a
buddy-cop duo it would be the good
couple to do that see when I think about
us I think more of CatDog I also love
the brulee it's that third texture that
you didn't know cheesecake needed yeah
this is the way to do it you take a bite
of the cheesecakes it bite it bite we're
not driving here so I like cheesecake
okay let's get something cheesy cake in
state give it to Adam ah what's that
Scott stop
these cake is a word that is hard to say
very fast very many times she teaches
whoa yeah cheesecake cheesecake
cheesecake cheesecake cheesecake she
can't she's came fast did you know that
cheesecakes appeared in the Wonder Girls
over a hundred times the Wonder Girls
note this card that shows go The Wonder
Years Oh were the Golden Girls it's the
Golden Girls
I believe sorry I nailed that fact we
are now on our way to the final
cheesecake spot the most expensive one
that we could find in New York City and
that is lady M my lady and we'll be able
to see everything in the taste with my
mouth eyeballs
my taste balls you got your eyeballs
your ear balls and your taste balls
my name is Renata I manage social media
for lady M in the M Julien I'm the
pastry chef lady hem it's all about the
experience that you have when you walk
into the boutique we have white walls
and we really like to keep all the focus
on the cake so got to nourish is French
and the new ice cream crowd so it's a
cloud to cloud care cake we have only
very simple ingredient cream cheese
sugar and eggs inside the top we're
finishing to decorate about the sour
cream little bit sugar inside I'm always
impressed by icing work when you're
rotating it really is that hard to do
when you start yeah because it's
difficult to spread the cream but after
our hundred cakes is so easy yeah if
it's the best cheese cake then yeah it's
definitely worth it yeah we think it's
worth it that's not for that Oh
this fancy shirt oh this place is right
up your alley
or you lactose-intolerant not intolerant
I'm just like to somewhat not cool with
it
[Music]
so this is kind of the first cheesecake
we've had that's more representative of
what I grew up eating it definitely
looks the most pristine yeah I like that
so Ilene's felt like the walking down
the street she's Kate STK had the party
cheesecake dinner and a show this one
however is I'm gonna go to the ball
she's King I'm expecting to be wait
creamier than the other ones we had it
feels nice and soft
she's cake
way creamier it's like the perfect bed
you're just like in this bed of cloud I
agree with you I think a great bed also
has a satisfying heaviness to it you're
kind of just like paralyzed under a
heavy blanket great jacket or blanket a
blanket okay okay Abhaya I definitely
prefer cheesecakes without any fruit or
other flavors am I crazy
I think here's the plastic guy that's
true I like being able to just really
slowly press my fork through the cake
here it's like you could really but I
could do a little barrel without that
right these kids that's why I can't go
anywhere with you
[Music]
yeah I put a hope sugar thing in there
that cheesecake was the ideal cheesecake
did it cut the cheese or did it take the
cake you like cheesecake that's both of
those got um which cheesecake was the
most worth it at its given price lady M
mmm does M stand for mmm I think
flavor-wise that was the one I liked the
most was it most worth it
I think Eileen's edges it out not only
do you get a delicious cheesecake how
often do you go to a place named after a
person and the person is there that's
like having George Washington hand you a
dollar bill what I loved about Eileen's
is just that I learned about what love
is but you know what STK is my hordes at
winter the orange zest plus two bourbon
plus the party atmosphere and the
cocktail altogether that is what I look
for in in dessert Adam what's your worth
it winner a to one another
food mystery solved good cop or bad cop
say you think you are on three one two
three good cop what you are definitely
bad guy the jackets you wear your spiked
hair you are the image of the bad boy
what oh yes